Цивілізація та достаток іноді мають досить неприємний присмак, точніше запах.
Ідеться про гори сміття.
Мегаполіси майбутнього мають шукати нові способи боротьби з відходами,
в іншому випадку матимуть перед будинком ось ТАКЕ.
Мерія Берліна вважає, що знайшла цьому рішення - тут, під Потсдамською площею.
Колись тут був Берлінський мур, нині – великий транспортний вузол та комерційний центр.
Щодня сюди приходять до 100 тисяч людей, залишаючи по собі до восьми тонн сміття.
Ніхто й не здогадується, що під ними на глибині 15 метрів прихована розгалужена система тунелів.
Сюди стікаються сміття та відходи з усіх ресторанів, кафе, крамниць.
А це чоловік, який допоміг планувати це підземелля.
Свою концепцію переробки сміття він вигадав ще у 90-ті.
Я пан Шульц, від фірми Альба.
Сміття реєструють та розділяють на місці.
Мета - відсортувати якомога більше цінних матеріалів у відходах.
Спеціальні працівники з точністю до 100 грамів
сортують відходи на папір, рештки продуктів та пластик.
Це називається "urban mining" – повторне використання міського сміття.
Із цих залишків роблять пюре, жир піде на виробництво косметики.
Воду викачують, щоб далі використовувати.
Залишаються лише малесенькі пластівці,
які відправляють у біогазову установку для виробництва енергії.
Із цих 15 тисяч контейнерів потрібно буде вивезти лише 5 тисяч.
Тобто дві третини обсягів і вартості вивезення оптимізовані.
І пан Шульц навіть оцифровує свої відходи.
Ці контейнери ми скануємо.
Система розпізнає, яким клієнтам вони належать,
відповідно до цього контейнери обліковуються та реєструються.
Сучасний хай-тек полегшує сортування: магніти витягують метали.
Майже половина усього заліза, що використовується у ФРН, - з відходів.
Спеціальна установка витягує пакети й фольгу.
Відсортовані матеріали видаються на виході у формі спресованих кубів.
Автоматизоване сортування міського сміття вже давно стало вигідним бізнесом.
Таким чином німецька промисловість заощаджує до 12 млрд євро на рік
на імпорті сировини з-за кордону.
Не таємниця, що населення Землі зростає швидкими темпами.
До 2050-го людство може обчислюватися 10 мільярдами.
Але гори сміття виростатимуть ще швидше.
Тож, рішення проблеми - сучасна підземна переробка сміття та автоматизація процесів.
Через те, що доставка, очистка тут досі відбуваються зі складнощами,
ми хочемо, можливо, запустити роботів з очистки на 5-кілометровий проміжок.
Багато зацікавлених з-за кордону, передусім з мегаполісів.
Вони дивляться на це і хочуть колись запозичити наш приклад.
Тут, під землею, ми дбаємо про довкілля,
не спричиняємо зайвого шуму на дорогах, жителі міста виграють від цього.
Так. Все автоматизовано, під землею відбуваються сервісні процеси, а на поверхні вирує яскраве життя.
Це не те яскраве життя, про яке говорив пан Шульц.
Але саме це залишають багато світових мегаполісів - гори сміття, в якому потопає планета.